welcome to this video playing I am new
new world champion as probably the
meaning of this this construction I
don't understand what is writing that no
it not very important okay we got a
closed closed Roy you're not going to
place you three here what are you going
to play a four is a movie our this is
just blundering your bishop here I mean
not blundering like giving it away but
you don't really want to give up your
your important rui bishop a tree is just
just a mistake
some strange move for an IM really but
it happens I can I can take it later
awesome
yeah it's not like like it's like
winning instantly or so but it's an
accomplishment to get rid of the bishop
here and it's um it's really helpful to
to get the bishop Pam I want to cover g5
if i can i can take later I don't want
to do this right away yeah maybe he will
try to try to get to f5 i will put the
bishop on f8 and maybe get to d5 played
be 65 later okay i want i want to
prevent Bishop g5 and then maybe Bishop
f8 Quincy 7 and d5 this type of this
type of position okay so he's trying to
do something in the center maybe with c4
could be a way to to make some s'amuser
firm of this trade on b3 my bishop a5
you can play but be age is not a quitter
square that our minds too much from the
Queen it's not not a problem
can play Bishop e6 may I can go see
five-year simply just see five yeah
maybe gain space I have if I've
protected by queen and rook
yeah he was he must decide now on the
structure yeah this is this is probably
a wise decision keeping it keeping it
closed so maybe prepare a five in the
long run
yeah I need to I need to get the Queen
over to the King side I wonder I wonder
how to how to set up the pieces is
obviously intending to play a form maybe
I can go here and go into da into
something like that I don't want to play
the Bishop to d7 at the moment what do
you have 97 if possible controlling the
e5 square and now if I go Quinn d8 i
guess so come on let's let's do that at
the rare occurrence we have some some
advantage showed the clock so better try
to keep that
hmm interesting very interesting that's
a good good play ready he's fighting for
the default square after this and FYE
will gain the default Graham good
positional move 97 maybe and quinto
difficult
difficult very difficult position
strategically very complex I I wanted to
okay
can do that right to get the Queen here
to support my play against their form
with what and don't tell me this is a
sacrifice that's working I will be
shocking mmm I have a way back so i take
now I wonder if and it's let's let's
think think for a moment what's the best
way to to play this maybe h5 actually
when you push this back push the night
back
the capture on g4 is also always
attacking the the rooks oh ok um take
with the pawn yeah I guess I'll take
with the pawn Knight takes rook takes
Bishop takes Queen a look at seven there
is Bishop age three year with a counter
made in a way ok here i can go Queen g5
yes I window is still open sorry this
was probably relatively loud you to
close it had this enormous fly in my
room I think it's now gone my g4 maybe
Nigel something easy I'm morning maybe
just he I am Bishop takes Bishop takes
root f7 rogue evade trading stuff it's
two pieces at the moment
yes really just just need to avoid any
big blunders and Queen g6 is the only
check here so I think I can just do this
check check
check white forfeit sunshine yeah all
this was was really unfortunate this
this blunder here was a very interesting
interesting strategical fight I think he
played as well with before before was a
good move it makes sure that the sea
pondus is leaving the bought and this
means that in this type of situation
when you place f4 and at some point I
need to move the pawn like taking on
something play a piece replacing it then
it's got the d4 square which wasn't
possible before so before was a good
move and probably just needs to play a 4
at some other point may be here even
maybe just interesting this position how
to how to play takes rook chicks now
let's say 97 this looks already quite
dangerous he's got this yeah it's got
this channel possibility or maybe here
complicated this looks good for what DNT
I was thinking okay he cannot play a 4
and then you went for it yeah I just
overlooked this but it's funny that the
computer says h5 is much stronger
interesting
the point is that F take c5 is not that
clear actually which surprises me why H
successor under fire interesting so this
is not really or not chanting here this
is winning for white what
I'm a bit baffled this is winning for
white why Wow there's also bishop you
won this is a big problem I was thinking
okay why not something like this yeah
but he's got he's got this idea and the
worst is this is this seemed stronger
wow wow okay that means every five is
very serious computer wants to check
with the look only giving black a slight
advantage check now that's totally
unrealistic I would never have gone for
that and what exactly has a slight
advantage in this position okay I can
exchange Queens ham funny funny
situation this looks good however I
think because I can always at the right
moment return the exchange this should
be okay interesting so every five still
what was the game in TR Chester I'm just
material up okay it's tough game thanks
for watching